bonjour à tous bienvenue seiler deux
parlements et 2 45 minutes ont fait le
tour de l'actu politique parlementaire
avec catherine bérubé côté mongeau katia
toujours dit qu'elle est de là qu cette
semaine évidemment dernière ligne droite
avant les élections départementales
match à distance qui se joue entre
manuel valls et nicolas sarkozy de
meeting en meeting les deux hommes n'ont
pas cessé de sauver des pics au coeur du
débat
encore et toujours leur nature autre
sujet la nouvelle loi sur le
renseignement deux mois après les
attentats de paris le texte a été
présenté en conseil des ministres il
donne de nouveaux moyens aux services
pour notamment surveiller ou géo
localiser les suspects la droite devrait
voter pour le projet de loi et puis le
plus de l'hebdo de cette semaine vous
présente un documentaire des chaînes
parlementaires intitulé vic de mer
cinquante deux minutes en immersion avec
filet lui et pour commenter cette
semaine notre invité est christian
estrosi
bonjour bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous dans parlement hebdo êtes député
maire ump de nice ancien ministre chargé
de l'industrie dans le gouvernement
fillon alors il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'actualité cette semaine beaucoup de
questions à vous poser on va commencer
par la politique michael et par les
élections départementales on commence
lundi manuel valls et nicolas sarkozy au
meeting dans le même département
lundi comme toute la semaine d'ailleurs
le premier ministre et le patron de
l'ump se livrent un duel à distance ils
étaient tous deux dans le département de
l'essonne
chacun ayant un petit mot amical en tout
cas on va le dire comme ça
l'un vers l'autre et les hameaux bagarre
manuel valls dans son fief politique
nicolas sarkozy dans un département qui
pourrait représenter une prise de guerre
lors des prochaines élections
départementales
les deux hommes ont tenu meeting à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres l'un de
l'autre
hier soir dans l'essonne vous le savez
sûrement ce soir il ya une autre réunion
dans le département
nicolas sarkozy n'attend pas longtemps
pour décocher les premières flèches
contre le premier ministre
voir comment il parle bien de la peur
monsieur valls j'aimerais pas être à sa
place
la vérité c'est que la france n'est plus
gouverné elle n'est plus gouverné plus
que monsieur valls préfère l'excès
l'excès des mots l'excès des postures
l'excès des états d'âme l'excès de
fébrilité
là où les français attendent
désespérément du sang froid de l'action
et les résultats manuel valls lui fin de
refuser l'affrontement à distance ce
n'est pas un duel de personnes ça n'est
pas un duel de coke à distance de
quelques kilomètres entre palaiseau evry
c'est un combat pour le pays
avant de répondre aux attaques de
l'ancien président de la république
nicolas sarkozy nous demande m'a demandé
de garder mes nerfs
c'est un spécialiste de la question mais
quand on est incapable
quand il est incapable de choisir entre
l'extrême droite et les républicains
entre le front national et la gauche il
démontre que non seulement il n'a pas de
nerfs mais qui n'a ni colonne vertébrale
ni conviction l'essonne théâtre hier
soir du match valse sarkozy car le
département est hautement symbolique
détenues par le ps depuis 1998 il
pourrait bien rebasculer à droite lors
des élections départementales
alors christian estrosi on va essayer de
s'arrêter un petit peu se soucier des
élections départementales et ce match un
peu à distance c'est étonnant que
nicolas sarkozy se met au même niveau
que manuel valls ancien président de la
république face au premier ministre n'a
pas quelque chose d'étonnant
bon d'abord je n'ai pas entendu parler
de l'essonne il s'agit d'un peu toute la
semaine non mais c'est votre reportage
qui
monte ainsi parce que je suis sûr que
l'ancien président de la république qui
connaît bien les sonne comme je la
connais bien pour m'y être souvent rendu
en tant que ministre de l'aménagement du
territoire ou de l'industrie a sûrement
dit des choses très intéressantes et
sans doute beaucoup plus intéressante
donc cela fait un journaliste puisque
c'est une terre industrielle
c'est une terre de production et que
nous venons d'avoir une première lecture
de la loi macron qui sur deux soit
réaliste oui on va peut-être en parler
mais enfin vous comprenez qu'il s'agit
d'une élection départementale et que moi
je ne suis pas là pour commenter les
petites phrases des uns et des autres je
suis là pour parler aux français je suis
là pour parler d'intérêt général je suis
là pour parler d'une élection locale et
pas du salon départemental
mais si monsieur valls n'a qu'une chose
à dire à répétition c'est qu'il a peur
que la france 2 se fracasse contre le
front national
mais monsieur le premier ministre si
vous avez peur il faut pas exiger
d'exercer les responsabilités qui sont
les vôtres
nous ne sommes pas là pour avoir peur
nous sommes là pour convaincre
convaincre que ce sont des candidats de
qualité attachés à des territoires
identifiés à des territoires et pas des
candidats dont on a rédigé la profession
comme en californie la politique paris
combien codifié et comment vous
qualifier la campagne mais ça ce n'est
par manuel valls
mais ça sert à quoi un département lors
qu'elle est finalement pas il n'y avait
pas le premier ministre ça m'est égal
il sait rien dit françois veillon mais
moi je ne portera pas de petits mots
contre les uns et les autres ça m'est
égal je veux me placer au dessus de ça
si ça fait plaisir à certains nation
procédure en cédant vous faites
explication parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on est une nationalisation et puis
envoyées ou si je fais exception tant
mieux moi je ne pense qu'à l'intérêt
général de mon pays et je ne pense qu'à
l'intérêt général de la france des
territoires et il s'agit d'une élection
qui touche à la france des territoires
où chaque territoire a sa spécificité où
nos candidats dans le département de
l'essonne
comme dans le mien non celui du
département des alpes-maritimes ont un
projet concret réel sur des compétences
qui touche essentiellement l'assemblée
départementale notamment dans le domaine
social puisque nous avons la
responsabilité de verser le rsa
puisque nous avons la responsabilité
eux d'accompagner notamment dans le
domaine de la dépendance les personnes
trop visualisation entre nationale et je
hais mais si on explique par exemple que
les candidats de ma formation politique
s'engage tous à ne pas augmenter la
fiscalité des départements là où le
gouvernement l'augmentent de à faire en
sorte que les prestations sociales ne
soient versés qu'à ceux qui font l'objet
de contrôles contre la fraude on l'a pas
suffisamment expliqué dans cette
campagne suffisamment rabat c'est sûr
que après que terna reportage comme
celui là c'est pas facile de l'expliquer
mais les ce que l'on demande avec sonic
et c'est la phrase sarkozy contre valls
et de valses confiance à un homme de foi
jaurès je reste le commentaire mais je
pense que l'on gère gurs nationale c'est
le respect de chaque territoire de
france qui le remet en voilà cette
commande en france vous ai pas paris
avec les petits mots qui par des
centrales politique parisienne c'est la
réalité de la vie des territoires de
france
le front national un bon quand même mais
le front national n'a trophée au genre
mais mais mais bien sûr nous tous on en
a trop fait par manque de respect des
électeurs ump comme ps mais par manque
de respect des électeurs ump ps médias
tout le monde je vois la part qu'on
donne en permettant à madame le pen
aujourd'hui de se dota belize et de ceux
des d abu lisez son rappeler ses
outrances et ses excès sans rappeler que
son programme relève plus un programme
d'extrême gauche d'un programme
l'extrême droite d'ailleurs je vois que
c'est plus des voix de gauche qui se
déplacent vers elle que des voix de
droite
exemple ce qui s'est passé dans le doubs
14 % de voix socialistes sont passés sur
le front national s'en expliquer que
quand on met un bulletin dans l'urne
pour madame le pen en même temps mais un
bulletin dans l'urne pour le bloc
identitaire
puisque vous avez des cantons de france
où ils vous avez sous l'étiquette bleu
marine un camp dont front national
candidat front national un candidat
identitaire condamné quelques pour
quelques-uns d'entre eux par le passé
pour l'incitation à la haine raciale et
l'antisémitisme et toutes ces choses je
sais pas j'ai eu dix mille articles on
n'en parle pas j'ai l'opportunité d'en
parler ce mal entier et maintenant on va
parler d'autres soucis voulait bien on
va passer à marmande avec marisol
touraine qui défend sa loi santé contre
vents et marées le projet de loi est
enfin arrivé à l'assemblée en commission
parlementaire il instaure notamment la
généralisation du tiers-payant c'est la
mesure phare les débats sont tendues
notamment un tweet d'arnaud robinet
député ump de reims a fait polémique je
découvre qu'un des symptômes d'une mst
et le mensonge mst pour marisol touraine
jeu de mots inadmissible pour la
ministre on écoute la coupe est pleine
au fond qui sont ceux qui se permettent
de parler de moi de cette manière là et
j'ai droit en tant que personne en tant
que femme en tant que ministre au
respect comme toute personne a droit
dans ce pays
moi je n'ai jamais parlé en d'autres
termes alors vous disiez que vous n'ayez
pas les petites phrases qu'ils aillent
trop est ce que ce genre de tweets de la
part d'un député maire pour vous et
digne d'un élu la république
d'abord comme tome acceptent d'exercer
des responsabilités n'accepte aussi de
temps en temps d'être écornée et de
prendre des coups qu'on se moque de nous
ça m'arrive quelquefois dans la loi
macro où je suis intervenu un certain
nombre d'heures l'assemblée nationale
monsieur macron a eu pour le
prédécesseur que je suis à l'industrie
des mots quelquefois assez dure jusqu'à
ce que des députés communistes le lui
reproche pour me défendre
donc là ils sont sous la porte voilà
contraints qu'ils aiment ça aussi bien
la pression et omeyer est tellement du
sont plus claires est ce que vous
demandez à madame le pen lorsque vous
l'invitez
pourquoi n'a pas pris les sanctions
qu'elle avait promis de prendre contre
jean marie le pen
lorsqu'il a dit de patrick bruel il fera
partie de la prochaine fournée
bon je pense que les si on pose des
questions on va jusqu'au bout et surtout
le monde question quand même sur le fond
le tiers payant on voit que les médecins
sont dans la rue ils sont accueillis
aussi par manuel valls
on leur promet une grande réunion à la
rentrée et la loi ils eux disent que la
loi sera votée ça ne sert à rien qu'est
ce que vous en pensez mais je dis qu'il
ya un préambule dans tous les domaines
que n'applique pas ce gouvernement
le préambule c'est la consultation c'est
la concertation s'est parlé avec les
professionnels or là vous voyez bien que
tout il ya eu ensuite bien d'autres
expositions qui nous sont imposées
aujourd'hui qui sont imposés aux
professionnels dans tous les domaines
c'était vrai pour les professions
juridiques par exemple dans la loi
macron sur la vente d'un certain nombre
d'actifs qui appartiennent en partie aux
collectivités dans la loi macron si par
exemple des arts e et le report est un
matériau n'a osé dans l'union et il n'y
a pas de concertation avant il faut pas
s'étonner qu'il y ait de telles
réactions cette loi sur la santé
je vais vous dire n'est pas à la hauteur
mais pire elle risque d'avoir des
conséquences extrêmement néfaste le
tiers payant c'est lenteur refus de
remboursement
l'inflation des soins le temps de
travail des médecins qui vont subir des
conséquences au même titre qu il y a
quelques années de cela les pharmaciens
par la lourdeur des démarches
administratives qu'ils doivent accomplir
maintenant n'ont plus le temps de se
consacrer à leurs clients mois face à
cela je trouve qu'il ya d'autres
propositions plus intéressantes à faire
on va rester dans le domaine de la santé
six mois après l'assemblée nationale je
préfère de la proposition va venir le
projet doit sur le vieillissement était
débattu au sénat il est centré sur le
maintien à domicile des personnes en
perte d'autonomie ce texte très attendu
depuis la canicule de 2003 sauvait une
première étape de la réforme de la
dépendance qui était une âme ont
repoussé plusieurs fois et il a semblé y
est aussi le texte sur la fin de vie qui
a été votée proposition de loi ump/ps
elle permet l notamment le recours à une
sédation profonde et continue pour
apaiser les souffrances du malade adopté
à une large majorité et pourtant
christian estrosi cette loi d
vise notamment au sein de votre parti il
en a qui disent que c'est un pas clair
vers l'euthanasie vous que dites vous
mais moi mais heureusement que quand il
s'agit d'un texte de loi qui touche à
l'humain ou c'est pas une vision de
droite ou de gauche c'est une
sensibilité une émotion personnelle
moi j'ai voté pour parce que je pense
que c'est une avancée importante contre
la souffrance tant pour le patient que
que pour les familles je peux comprendre
divise aussi dans votre choquant je peux
opale divise à gauche et à droite
bon parce qu'on est sur des lois qui
touche à l'humain qui diviseront
toujours donc je ne vais pas le
contester
moi je dis qu'à titre personnel je
trouve que cette loi est bonne et
qu'elle est une évolution importante
maintenant vous m'avez fait parler de la
réforme de madame touraine qui est une
mauvaise loi pour la santé des femmes
sortaient oui mais c'est une proposition
de loi du groupe ump et le deux
parlementaires un ump et un socialiste
qui ensemble se sont mis d'accord ce qui
est une très belle image d'ailleurs de
deux parlementaires qui défendent
l'intérêt général avec une même vision
des choses et moi j'aime cette image je
l'ait soutenu j'ai adhéré la loi de tout
raide c'est la loi de touraine et c'est
la loi du gouvernement et pas les
managers de représenter la structure
c'est bien différent et donc je trouve
qu'en matière de santé voyez nous
aurions dû trouver dans cette fois
touraine
plutôt que de vouloir amener le privé le
public à s'affronter au contraire à les
rassembler il se trouve qu'à nice j'ai
fondé validé par le gouvernement
précédent confirmée par le gouvernement
actuel
le centre national de référence santé
qui s'appelle désormais france silver
échos c'est à dire que c'est à la fois
une filière qui peut unir unifier le
public et le privé autour d'une filière
industrielle qui accompagnent des start
up sur les nouvelles technologies
nous avons une qualité de soins en
france par exemple où un accident
cardiaque
on sait soigner ça tout de suite
parfaitement bien mais derrière il y a
les risques de maladies chroniques
il y a les insuffisances crise cardiaque
est censé pas sur elle suivi et le
meilleur suivi
c'est donner l'autonomie le maintien à
domicile
la qualité de vie grâce à l'aide des
nouvelles technologies sur lesquelles
l'exemple on avait six passes et sur les
politiques de prévention
c'est tout cela que j'aurais aimé
trouver dans la loi madame lorraine et
c'est tout le confort est en débat à
l'assemblée vous voulez parler d'elle au
maquereau en hiver ce mercredi au sénat
il ya une commission spéciale qui se
penche sur la loi du ministre de
l'économie emmanuel macron est venue ce
mardi et ce mercredi en discuter avec
les sénateurs socialistes notamment on
l'écoutera clé une volonté de régler
enfin j'espère en tout cas pas ce qu'on
a dit ça ça me fera des vagues il ya
toujours des précisions à apporter des
améliorations
le gouvernement est prêt à avancer sur
certaines améliorations du texte le
premier ministre a eu l'occasion de le
dire il s'agit pas de transformer cette
fois ou de faire la loi d'une majorité
qui n'est pas la majorité
gouvernementale
il est prêt à l'ouverture il est prêt à
des négociations il est prêt à aller un
petit peu plus loin son doigt j'imagine
aller dans votre sens que je vais être
content là j'ai eu un entretien pour la
première fois après l'avoir réclamé
pendant trois ans audi ce mercredi avec
emmanuel macron bien c'était sa première
loi de toute évidence elle m'a conquis
et sans doute un homme de talent et qui
est intelligent mais inexpérimenté au
plan politique c'est un peu cassé le nez
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'être
obligé de la faire voter par le 49-3 au
bout de trois semaines de débats
c'est quand même un échec je crois il
est en train d'en tirer les conséquences
tant mieux mais vous avez parlé avec lui
donc c'est un homme dangereux diane j'ai
parlé sur un certain nombre
il était fermé jusqu'à être obligé de
faire voter sa loi par le 49-3 bon un
homme de dialogue
depuis je m'en réjouis j'ai eu un
entretien dans de grandes qualités mais
vous parlé avec le ministre
pardon de quoi avez vous parlé avec le
mannose avons parlé tout simplement de
de l'avant d'un certain nombre
d'intérêt stratégique que je considère
comme stratégique aéroports dont
l'aéroport international de nice mais
j'y lis celui de lyon qui font partie
tous les deux de l'article 49 et dont il
faut tirer les conséquences de la vente
de l'aéroport de toulouse un consortium
chinois et où je vois que derrière
pourrait arriver la vente de l'aéroport
de bordeaux où alain juppé lui-même est
en train de se mobiliser
de son côté avec ses partenaires ça au
final ça arrive à quoi tout ça ça arrive
à ce que au sénat emmanuel macron
acceptent des amendements qui seront
proposées notamment par le rapporteur
pour avis la sénatrice dominique estrosi
sassone qui vont de l'accord qui vont
donner un traitement ils vont sur
l'alinéa 2 et et l'alinéa 4 permettent
le comte changent les mots à la fois
opérateurs par gestionnaire ce qui
compte ça veut dire que c'est pas des
pays demain qui prendra sous tutelle les
aéroports régionaux de dimension
internationale
et deuxièmement que nous puissions aussi
avoir un droit de veto sur le choix des
actionnaires et aussi est aussi un
cahier des charges qui pourraient être
en 12 ou 15 fois qui sera finalisé à
l'assemblée nationale ensuite dans
lequel nous pourrions garder la maîtrise
de la stratégie économique du
développement économique du territoire
et en même temps mettre un certain
nombre de garde-fous pour que nous
assurer que nous le sommes pas racheté
par vous avez des consortiums dubaïote
aujourd'hui le ministre va donner des
assurances et en plus que sur la part
des 60 % de l'état puisque nous
conserverons nos 40 % près de 10% puisse
être réinjectés dans le contrat de plan
sur les cinq ans qui viennent pour le
financement des infrastructures
territoriale et connell de transport
dont nous avons besoin plan territorial
et bien c'est bien compris mercredi on
va passer à une autre actualité puisque
l'assemblée nationale s'est prononcé sur
le cas de patrick balkany son immunité
parlementaire a été levée pour permettre
à la justice de poursuivre son travail
réactions de vos collègues au
palais-bourbon recueillis par
charleville à limbé côté il ne peut pas
y avoir de protection particulière parce
qu'on est député ou parce qu'on les
sénateurs quand la justice de faire son
travail dans quête offert son travail de
jugement le moment venu elle doit
pouvoir le faire
c'est à la justice de dire si patrick
balkany a connu des choses qui sont
illégales ou pas et on est dans un état
de droit quand on est innocentes et on
est innocentes et quand on est coupable
on est condamné si on peut faire le
ménage c'est très bien à quelques jours
des élections
moi j'appelle aussi les électeurs à bien
faire la différence entre ceux qui se
croient au dessus des lois de la
république et ceux qui travaillent sur
le terrain
l'action très claire cette décision
était attendue est ce qu'elle est
justifiée pour vous moi je vous
répondrai simplement comme certains
l'ont fait notamment thierry solère que
l'assemblée nationale laisse le soin à
la justice de décider s'il est juste ou
pas d'engager des poursuites contre
patrick balkany laissons la justice
faire son travail il dit qu'il a été
jeté aux chiens
j'ai de l'amitié dû respect pour patrick
balkany
maintenant nous sommes des citoyens
comme les autres et donc nous devons
montrer aux français que nous pouvons
être jugés comme les autres et que c'est
à la justice de dire les choses c'est
pour être complet sachez que le même
jour le bureau du sénat a levé
l'immunité parlementaire d'un sénateur
udi aymeri de montesquiou dans le cadre
d'une enquête sur les soupçons de
commissions en marge des contrats
conclus avec le kazakhstan voilà c'était
pour être complet sur ce niveau là on va
reparler des élections départementales
christian estrosi et des incidences
aussi sur votre parti on va parler
d'alain juppé
vous savez que le maire défend de
stratégie d'alliance de droite du centre
et de tous les centres il a été en
meeting à tourcoing dans le nord à côté
d'eux notamment gérald darmanin gérald
darmanin c'est un proche de nicolas
sarkozy
on va voir ça avec jardin andrieu c'est
l'autre patron de l'ump alain juppé est
en campagne au côté de gérald darmanin à
tourcoing son objectif convaincre pour
les départementales sans oublier 2010 16
dans la voix du nord l'ancien premier
ministre est clair il refuse toute
droite isation de l'ump et de courir
après le front national
cela positionne depuis bien longtemps je
pense que la seule voie pour gagner face
à un front national qui continue à
progresser c'est de faire une solide
alliance entre la droite et le centre et
je constate que c'est ce que nous
faisons par tous sur le thème y compris
ici d'ailleurs à la tribune les élus
locaux appellent à la mobilisation
nous sommes capables de faire changer
les choses mais pour ça il faut que nous
mobilisions beaucoup plus d'autres camps
que la gauche devra savoir le faire ces
quelques dizaines de voix feront la
différence et nous permettront de gagner
quant à la menace du front national et
des alertes de manuel valls
alain juppé renvoie le gouvernement à
ses propres responsabilités
la première raison de la montée du front
national aujourd'hui il faut quand même
le rappeler c'est l'échec du président
de la république et du gouvernement
socialiste
la seule force politique qui puisse
barrer la route au front national c'est
très clair c'est l'alliance de la droite
et du sandre ce que vous avez fait ici
et ceux qui préfèrent partout une
stratégie électorale qui divise sur la
question du modem au sein même de l'ump
où tout est à reconstruire
avant les primaires pour 2017 c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une phase de
construction de construction dans le
pays puisque élections municipales
départementales régionales de
construction pour choisir notre candidat
à la primaire et de construction
idéologique
donc chacun droitier entendent bien
évidemment sa musique crois que de
manière générale trop modéré outre pas
droite ne va pas dans le corps social
qui attend les français
prochaine étape le congrès de la
refondation du parti prévues fin mai
xavier bertrand alain juppé françois
fillon bruno le maire
ou encore nicolas sarkozy pour le moment
chacun joue sa propre partition
en attendant le résultat des primaires
prévues au plus tard à l'automne 2016 ah
je vous interroger sur alain juppé bien
entendu où on accueille jean jarrassé du
partenaire du figaro et ça me fait
sourire
ça vous fait sourire bah tant mieux il
paraît qu'il est sur un nuage alain
juppé c'est vrai vous savez j'ai fait
mes propres meeting à la demande d'un
grand nombre d'amis qui m'ont accompagné
moi aussi à strasbourg à carpentras à
montpellier je peux vous commenter mes
meetings vous me demandez de commenter
ceux d'alain juppé je préfère commenter
les miens au coffrage et bien je n'y
étais pas donc je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est dit
à part un bref résumé tout ce que je
peux vous dire lesquin à juppé alain
juppé est un homme d'une grande qualité
que nous avons à l'inter de notre
formation politique des hommes de grande
qualité qui ont tous de petites
différences de toutes petites
différences en matière de sensibilité
pas énormes ce sens a montré pas dans la
même formation politique on ne
travaillerait pas ensemble à la
reconstruction à travers un congrès de
30 juste une question de fond questions
de fond sur l'alliance des tous les
centres avec une vidéo sur des machines
à l'eau jusqu'aux modèles vous êtes
favorable à cela mais vous savez tout ça
c'est de la tambouille politicienne
si vous saviez mon parce que ça ne soit
saisie l'animé plateaux de télévision
les gens qui nous écoutent
combien ils en ont ras le bol des
attitudes politiciennes
ils veulent qu'on parle de projets
d'avenir de la france de l'intérêt
général
vous m'avez offert l'opportunité de
faire des propositions dans le domaine
de la santé
j'en ai à faire dans le domaine de la
lutte contre le terrorisme la sécurité
qui est un problème majeur en prenant la
3ème guerre mondiale aujourd'hui c'est
quand même pas rien c'est plus important
que les alliances entre le centre et le
modem semble-t-il que de pouvoir
éradiquer le terrorisme doit me servir
les futures saisons au front national je
vais vous dire une chose certains
commettent une erreur
il pense que c'est pour de simples
problèmes liés à l'insécurité qu'il ne
faut pas nier et où nous avons aussi
notre part de responsabilité et je
l'assumé pas proposer le croit savoir à
la nasa voix de ne pas à vous
lorsque nous étions gouvernement ait
pris toutes les mesures nécessaires
alors que nous avions pourtant
parfaitement réussi lorsque nicolas
sarkozy était ministre de l'intérieur
entre 2002 et 2005 vous le regrettez ça
je regrette qu'elle ne soit pas allée
plus loin
mais par contre je suis convaincu que ce
qui amène à voter pour les extrêmes à
gauche comme à droite aujourd'hui c'est
plus une souffrance c'est plus la crise
économique
c'est plus la perte de croissance c'est
plus le chômage c'est plus la dignité
par le logement et que si on ne répond
pas toutes ces problématiques pour les
français si on n'est pas capable de
faire des propositions innovantes dans
tout ça ils attendent c'est ce qu'attend
impression que vous savez vous avez sur
n'est pas capable d'arriver au minimum à
3% de croissance 0,3 point de croissance
ça écrème un milliard d'euros de
recettes dans les caisses de l'état
trois points c'est 30 milliards
c'est-à-dire un peu moins de la moitié
de ce que rapporte l'impôt sur le revenu
et ça ferait sans doute baisser le
chômage de 20 à pure routine sans si on
n'arrivait pas à aller jusqu'à 7 3%
qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'ai dit simplement que c'est la cata
vous savez vous avez monsieur hollande
qui dit je veux arracher des électeurs
du front national
1 les électeurs n'appartiennent à
personne ils appartiennent pas au front
ils n'appartiennent pas à l'ump ils
n'appartiennent pas au parti socialiste
un électeur est libre et moi je dit à
monsieur hollande il faut pas essayer
d'arracher il faut convaincre
moi je suis là pour convaincre je suis
là pour faire des propositions pour se
dire tiens
peut-être qu'à travers quelqu'un comme
ça les engagements donnés se
transformeront en elle comme sa venue
c'est pour ça que je suis réélu
régulièrement dans ma bonne ville de
nice
eh ben je vous propose justement de
passer sous la loupe du scan notre
partenaire pour cette émission
alors jean jé ration va parler des
ambitions de christian estrosi fait vous
voulez pas qu'on parle d'un alain juppé
voulait qu'on parle de vous on va parler
de vous lugo qu'on parle de l'intérêt
général et ben parlons-en justement au
début de l'été dernier vous aviez
annoncé que vous étiez prêts à vous
présenter à la cambre à la primaire de
l'ump en 2016 à condition que nicolas
sarkozy n'y aille pas aujourd'hui
nicolas sarkozy est président l'ump a
priori semble plutôt enclin à vouloir se
présenter à la primaire de l'ump est ce
que vous christian estrosi
vous êtes candidat aujourd'hui à cette
primaire de l'ump on vous sent vous avez
envie de faire des propositions j'avais
dit deux choses
j'avais un je suis candidat aux
primaires
il ne me semble pas depuis avoir dit le
contraire la deuxième chose que j'avais
dit c'est imaginons parce qu'il faut
jamais dire jamais je vois tout ce
qu'ils disent jamais renoncé
vous savez en politique j'ai vu tant de
situations après avoir déjà mais en est
revenue en arrière mais j'avais dit la
deuxième chose si nicolas sarkozy à 200%
dans le moindre détail en matière de
politique de croissance d'innovation de
lance de la politique de logement de
santé dont nous venons de parler de
lutte contre le terrorisme des moyens
mettre en oeuvre pour lutter contre
l'insécurité
on était à 100% d'accord ça serait de
candidature inutile et il vaudrait mieux
concentrer nos énergies
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy 1 n'a pas
fait savoir s'il serait candidat donc il
n'y a aucune raison que je revienne en
arrière et ne me semble pas depuis un an
est revenu une seule fois en arrière sur
mon choix de proposer un certain nombre
de choses sur lesquelles j'ai travaillé
j'ai réfléchi je propose règlement je
rencontre des spécialistes
deuxièmement je pense que sur un certain
nombre de sujets oui j'ai des choses à
dire
bon il se trouve que par exemple je ne
crois au retour de la croissance que par
le financement de l'innovation
vous êtes près les ficelles d'un c'est
un sujet sur lequel nous avons
une grande contradiction lorsque j'étais
ministre de l'économie entre christine
lagarde et moi d'ailleurs j'ai dû
quitter le gouvernement en décembre 2010
à procéder à toutes ces propositions
visent à ce que vous vous irez jusqu'au
pas là mais je dis que c'est formidable
avoir l'opportunité de montrer aux
français que nous avons à prendre des
engagements de vente eux et qu'ils
puissent avoir le choix pour se
convaincre que c'est plutôt untel ou
unetelle qui apportera de vraies
solutions et dont ils sentiront dans le
regard biais car s'il est clair vous
dites oui je suis candidat jusqu'au
bruit mais je suis candidat aux
primaires
aujourd'hui nous rédigeons cette charte
des primaires je me réjouis que nicolas
programmé aujourd'hui et je reconnais et
je remercie nicolas sarkozy savait il ya
un nom savait pas si on aborderait des
départementales aussi bien structurelles
que nous ne le sommes aujourd'hui nous
le devons pour beaucoup au rôle qu'a
joué à nicolas sarkozy et à son
influence à sa patience pour pouvoir
fédérer montceau-les-mines pas sur
celles de niveau de l'organisation de
l'ump puisque pour l'instant la
responsabilité nicolas sarkozy c'est la
présidence de l'ump
voilà mais j'ai mes idées à des français
j'ai résidé à défendre vous 0 degré à
défendre
j'ai des idées à défendre que je
défendrai au primaire c'est clair et
c'est clair sarkozy juppé fillon vous
donc nathalie kosciusko morizet
peut-être bruno le maire est ce que
l'ump ça devient pas un peu le club
dépôt des candidats à la primaire j'ai
pas envie d'en parler plus que ça vous
m'avez posé une question j'ai répondu
est ce que vous trouvez que vis-à-vis de
nos candidats au départemental où nous
devons nous montrer tous unis pour
dimanche prochain où nous devons
démontrer que nous avons d'abord un
programme pour ces élections
départementales sur lequel nous sommes
tous d'accord pour les soutenir pour
qu'ils aillent à la conquête des
départements de france et en tant que
président de la commission nationale
d'investiture
retenez cela pour le dimanche 29 au soir
vous m'appellerez je suis à peu près des
régionales les régionales vous y aller
ou pas que nous conte que nous gagnerons
mais retenait seul chiffre que nous
gagnerons environ entre 20 et 25
présidences de conseils généraux sur la
gauche le 29 mars au soir
voilà je vous laisse je vous l'annonçais
ce sont mes calculs très bien voilà je
ne vais pas aller plus loin dans un
débat qui se tiendra en 2016 alors que
des blocs début 2015 question beaucoup
plus sur les régionales qui arriveront
bientôt en décembre prochain candidat ou
pas vous ne répondez oui non peut être
écouté je me suis engagé parce que en
région provence alpes côte d'azur
il ya un vrai débat c'est la candidature
de jean-marie le pen
nous allons les chiffres des sondages et
cetera à prendre toute ma part de
responsabilité pour que jean marie le
pen ne gagne pas cette région et que ma
formation politique puisse l'emporter
donc je ne vous répond qu'une chose
c'est que je prendrai toute ma part
aso djimba je dirai le moment venu la
forme que cela prendra
djemila questions sur l'islam la
question sur l'islam en effet a fait
irruption la campagne cette semaine
oui mais il ya eu la décision du maire
ump de châlons sur saône de supprimer
les menus sans porc dans les cantines
qui a qui a créé un peu la polémique
nicolas sarkozy à autre chose que le
seul débat de l'islam qui s'est ouvert
il ya eu aussi le débat sur le voile
dans l'université qui est revenue dans
l'actualité
nicolas sarkozy a soutenu le maire de
chalon d'autres à l'ump sont beaucoup
plus réticents jean claude jean pierre
raffarin claude goasguen rachida dati ce
matin ils disent il faut avant tout à
apaiser la société avant d'aborder vous
savez vous en tant que maire qui vous en
pensez mais c'est parce que j'en pense
et ce que je fais oui il ya le
commentaire puis à l'action j'ai repris
en régie directe alors que c'était géré
depuis trente ans par le privé les 163
cantine scolaire de la cinquième ville
de france nice pour devenir moi-même en
quelque sorte le chef cuistot j'ai
confiée au professeur nutritionniste de
présider le
un comité de scientifiques concernés
donc dans deux cars une bio de qualité
tous les jours à chacun de nos élèves et
en même temps bien évidemment à l'entrée
scolaire
nous demandons aux familles je mets de
côté je ne veux pas entendre parler ni
dada nidal al ni de cacher bien
évidemment mais quand on est issu d'une
famille où l'éducation fait qu' on ne
mange pas de porc
je ne veux pas imposer à des enfants de
consommer du porc
voilà pour avoir nous faisons des menus
différencier parce que c'est aussi le
respect que j'ai pour une éducation qui
est donnée à la maison moi je me
rappelle je suis issue d'une famille
chrétienne le vendredi nous mangions du
poisson c'était la règle et aujourd'hui
je veux qu'on continue à respecter cette
règle c'est ce que j'apporte donc c'est
d'y aller avant le paseo je dis merci
merci d'être intervenu au massif et sur
la loi du renseignement qui a été
examiné en conseil des ministres une loi
examiné en conseil des ministres avec
des nouveaux moyens pour le
renseignement vois ça que jean baptiste
daoulas manuel valls se dévoile un
catalogue de mesures pour lutter contre
le terrorisme
avec d'abord la création de 2680 emploi
dans les trois prochaines années dans
l'ensemble des administrations
concernées
outre des moyens en personnel et en
matériel il est bien sûr indispensable
de donner une base légale à l'activité
de nos services de renseignement
parce qu'ils agissent discrètement voir
secrètement quand c'est nécessaire
leur action réelle et reconnu peut-être
source de fantasmes sans fondement ou de
critique des cas les protéger dans le
respect des libertés
c'est l'ambition affichée par le premier
ministre avec un renforcement des moyens
de surveillance les interceptions de
sécurité seront légalisés conversation
téléphonique boîtes mails réseaux
sociaux les écoutes pourront être
archivée pendant un mois plus
controversé l'utilisation d'appareils
permettant de capter toutes les
communications dans un périmètre donné
sera légalisée de
même que l'obligation pour les acteurs
du web de signaler aux autorités des
comportements suspects de leurs
utilisateurs
de quoi inquiéter la cnil et le conseil
national du numérique
aucune mesure de surveillance ne pourra
être effectuée sans autorisation
préalable et sans contrôle indépendant
cette loi sera aussi protectrice des
citoyens car les limites de ce qu'il est
possible de faire dans un état de droit
seront gravés dans le marbre
il n'y aura plus de zone grise une
commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement sera créé
pour éviter les dérives et la protection
des libertés sera au coeur des
discussions au parlement le mois
prochain
nicolas sarkozy a dit que cette loi
était satisfaisante car en l'état ou
votre retour à l'assemblée nationale
bien évidemment je voterai pour je
dirais même qu'il était temps nous ont
fait beaucoup de propositions dans ce
domaine vous savez nous sommes rentrés
dans la troisième guerre mondiale
nous on a connu le stalinisme le nazisme
il ya aujourd'hui l'islam au fascisme et
nous avons affaire à des cinquièmes
colonnes rampante qui avance comme des
lâches
camouflé derrière des réseaux sociaux et
je pense que les mesures qui sont
proposés sont de bonnes mesures
je les soutiendrai de toutes mes forces
un temps j'entends les réserves de la
cnil je me retrouve un peu dans les
propos des révolutionnaires de 1789 qui
disait pas de liberté pour les ennemis
de la liberté
eh bien je dis très clairement pas de
liberté contre les kidnappeurs pack de
liberté contre les violeurs pas de
liberté contre les égorgeurs pas de
liberté contre les apprentis djihadistes
excellent terreau et c'est là où madame
taubira considère que la prison est
criminogène
je dis pas de liberté pour tous ceux là
voilà ce que je souhaite aussi que nous
retrouvions dans nos lois avec des
quartiers spécifiques pour les
islamistes en prison la création d'un
fichier des personnes et on balaie
l'instauration d'un délit de
consultations régulières des sites
terroristes
car nous avons une faiblesse si on est
tous d'accord sur le fait que partir en
syrie c'est devenir un jihadiste et que
si on a la double nationalité
on ne peut pas revenir parce qu on vous
supprime la nationalité française
vous allez le problème de celui qui ne
va pas jusqu en syrie mais qui est
chaînon qui se radicalise comme le
moussa coulibaly qui a tenté d'égorger
séminaire à nice devant le consistoire
et celui là on n'a pas pu l'empêcher de
le faire pourquoi parce qu'aucune
disposition dans notre droit ne fait que
quand on est en contact par un réseau
social avec les djihadistes c'est un
délit je trouvais à côte sur scène il y
aura il y aura d'autres moyens désormais
mandatant sait bien que les démocraties
restent vulnérables à ce genre d'attaqué
qu'on peut essayer de prévenir au
maximum et la vraie question aussi quand
on essaie de lutter contre le terrorisme
est ce que ce n'est pas aussi le nerf de
la guerre donc l'argent donc en gros
s'attaquer à ceux qui permettent de
délivrer des pays dont on sait vous avez
raison moi j'avais raison que ça et
c'est là que je trouve complètement
incohérente la politique diplomatique de
la france
pourquoi ça va peut-être choquer ceux
qui m'écoutent et quand je vois qu'on
refuse de livrer deux mistral à la
russie
pourtant la russie est confrontée aux
mêmes problèmes que les nôtres en
matière de terrorisme et de terrorisme
islamiste simplement parce que par le
dialogue on n'a pas été capable de
régler en 24 heures comme les faits
nicolas sarkozy pour la géorgie
le problème de la crimée et que dans le
même temps se vante de livrer 24 rafale
à l'egypte c'est donc dans cet art dont
on ne sait pas si demain les frères
musulmans ne reprendrons pas le pouvoir
ne retourneront pas les 24 heures à
falcon c'était une erreur
quand je vois qu'en même temps on fait
voter par le parlement français
une résolution unilatérale pour la
création d'un état palestinien alors que
monsieur netanyahou dont je me réjouis
de la réélection lutte de toutes ses
forces contre un autre mouvement
terroriste qui s'appelle leur âme à la
france se trompe d yvan colonna et
vendre demain vers rafale au qatar
qu'elle était un allié de l'état haslam
est atteint je ne comprends plus rien à
cette police générale stratégies mais
bon sang
la russie qui sont nos amis qui ont fait
travailler l'industrie française et ont
sauvé des centaines de salariés la dcn à
brest israël qui est notre ami de touche
pour la plupart des grandes démocraties
unissons nous tous ensemble pour mettre
un terme à ce qui est la troisième
guerre mondiale
sans ça nous n'en viendrons pas à bout
ce qui s'est passé à tunis
avant-hier est extrêmement significatif
alors qu'un président démocrate avait
été élu en tunisie nous voyons comment
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas une guerre mon
nom d'une religion et c'est une guerre
autour d'un idéal politique pour mettre
à mal les piliers fondateurs des grandes
démocraties on a compris notre message
on referme cette page d'actualité et on
va passer avec un sujet un peu plus
léger le plus de l'hebdo qui vous
présente cette semaine un documentaire
intitulé vie de mère mère que vous êtes
le portrait de six élus qu'ils engagent
pour leur commune c'est à voir sur
public sénat le 4 avril
petit avant goût avec simon barbarie je
me sentais perdue quoique soutien que je
reçois pas une formation politique ne te
dis pas voilà tu y es politiques mais le
guide toutes formes toi même
et oui pas facile d'être mère loin des
micros et des projecteurs de la
télévision 5 124 mille élus de terrain
incarne le premier maillon de notre vie
démocratique dans ce documentaire inédit
widmer le réalisateur pascal carcanade
en a suivi six maires adjoints hommes
femmes vieux routard ou novices tous
parlent de leur engagement pour leur
commune
une implication de chaque instant un
véritable sacerdoce républicain quand on
s'est rencontrés je savais qu'il était
élu je voyais pas forcément bien ce que
ça impliquait on réalise pas vraiment le
temps que ça peut prendre et l'énergie
que ça peut prendre même en dehors des
réunions ça irrite vraiment toute la vie
fluidité des séquences sincérité des
témoignages ce documentaire prend la
forme d'un outil pédagogique le dos ou
de l'écharpé tricolore comme on ne l'a
jamais vu c'est le constat d'un maire
créateur de lien social et non celui
d'un décideur tout-puissant l'état
resserré je dirais les moyennes des
communes gérer un budget
c'est pas faire des emprunts à tout prix
tout va il ya des limites d'un homme
budget il faut savoir ne pas dépasser
ses limites
loin des débats partisans ou des
scandales vie de mère redore le blason
de l'engagement politique
à voir avant d'aller voter christian
estrosi être mère être maire c'est le
plus beau mandat d'un élu pour vous
c'est bien sûr le plus beau puisque
cette saison les français disent qu'ils
y sont le plus attachés c'est celui qui
vous permet d'avoir un regard réel sur
les épreuves les difficultés
quotidiennes mais de peser aussi sur des
leviers qui crée de la croissance et de
l'emploi
contrairement à m vous savez quand le
gouvernement dit on fait une loi pour la
croissance et que dans la loi macron sur
200 articles il n'y a pas une mesure
pour la production industrielle pour
l'innovation pour la recherche pour le
développement et que je développe mois
une technopôle urbaine ou en moins de
trois ans sont implantés ibm cisco edf
gdf suez et caetera et caetera et ont
apporté des ressources fiscales
nouvelles et créer des emplois près de
4500 emplois c'est le maire qui peut
agir là dessus en même temps qu'il peut
répondre aux préoccupations sociales au
pouvoir d'achat aux coûts sur les
cantines scolaires pour les familles qui
sont en dessous d'un quotient familial
au ticket de transport 1 euro à la
baisse du coût de l'eau 14% de moins en
mois de ma mère souffre de faire le même
c'est à dire que le maire c'est le vrai
élus des territoires
c'est un économiste américain je termine
là dessus qu'ils disaient si le monde
était gouvernée par les maires ça
marcherait beaucoup mieux et d'amasser
bonne journée et à ses fidèles aux
chaînes parlementaires
hu